[Applause]
yeah I'm so hungover
oh my gosh that's the worst oh my God
and he actually I was walking I love
when I walk in and glow my makeup artist
I'm like I'm sorry like it's like my
face looks strange yeah you're gonna
earn that money today this stuff you
know that you fill in the walls where do
you call it poly filler here you know if
there's a hole in the wall and you try
and make it look better I need a lot of
that power to my face today yes well
thank you for being here that's I'm here
because it's you oh gosh I love you
well welcome back to the show and it's
summertime now so what do you do for
summer do you want holiday do you need
anything fun well I try to because
obviously I don't know when you guys
have your your school holidays but ours
are like end of July until the beginning
of September oh it's shorter yeah ours
is then really glad I'm American right
now yeah yeah
window of sun we're like oh
that's amazing I didn't think about that
yeah oh where did you go did you ever do
anything fun well did you do like family
trips growing up well yes we did
actually my my mum's an opera singer or
was yeah before she retired so we would
go like on her Opera tour with her
that's incredible so many places yeah
incredible yeah and we but the first
knowledge I had of America was like
Austin and New Orleans
yeah yeah your first entrance to America
was Texas that's awesome yeah very
different but yeah but also like the
because she was singing you know that
the um the Metropolitan Opera House in
New York yeah and so that was my first
little thing you know obviously being a
singer
is that when you kind of figured out
like I want to be a singer as well like
I think so I mean what were you I was
like people ask me that I'm like I don't
remember wanting to do anything else and
when I heard that people had like
grown-up jobs I remember thinking they
they want why would you do that yeah not
just sing dance and act
honestly I couldn't compute it yeah I
love that what an amazing childhood I
remember going I'm the opposite I was
brought up where you just had like real
jobs and then I was like wait you can
make money doing that you know I was
just like wait really and yeah I thought
that was I think because I was in his
influence I I didn't think they were
surprised when yeah I wanted nothing to
do with a grown-up professional cubicle
yeah yeah well our daughters are about
the same age does she get to travel with
you because you get to travel so much
yes but I'm finding now that she's I
find it really inconvenient that she's
at school I wanted to come out and play
with Me Mine finds it inconvenient too
she wants to go with me yeah yeah they
got to that age where you kind of have
to respect their education yeah you know
which is pretty cool but I'm gonna try
and bring her a bit more and maybe bring
a tutor or something because coming to
things like this for her to see us our
girlies seeing us working and how
important that's an education yeah that
women are just like I'm getting out
there so I I agree with that too it is
obviously we love school too but I love
school very important so wait does she
know like when you were traveling does
she know that her mom once got kicked
out of a hotel I don't know what you're
talking about
sir look look I just say that there if
you're going to leave a Hostess trolley
in a corridor when people have had a
little beverage you're inviting trouble
but you were inviting trouble so I lay
on top of it my friend lay like threw it
and another friend of ours like pushed
us down the corridor and we accidentally
smacked into this you know when the
wheels are like
yeah smacked into this thing and this
woman opens the door and goes well thank
you very much I just got my baby to
sleep and we had to go downstairs and
sign a thing saying we'd never come back
to the hotel yeah
here's my thing I heard this story and I
was like that got you kicked out yes do
you know what kinds of things I have
seen and heard on tours
I can't even I was like wow yeah a lot
of people I know would have yeah
and I actually thought they would get
because I was there to do all my
fittings for for Spamalot on Broadway
yeah and I thought oh my God they're
gonna think I'm an English reprobate
honestly yeah not good
the season finale of Ted lasso is is
about to happen and I've heard it might
be the end end is it the end well I
don't know I mean it says it's like the
end of that three season Arc oh
interesting yeah I mean I feel like
trapping him in a dungeon with a notepad
and a pen so good I'm just going dude
what are you doing you can't step away
from it the characters are so beloved
and we all love it I mean I would play
her when her teeth are falling out in a
retirement home like sitting outside it
with mud splashing her you know yeah I
would I just want to see her through
yeah I love the idea that though of
almost taking a show and doing it in
different like almost how they do it
like Marvel you know what I'm saying
you'd see different characters and
different things that's a cool idea
y'all should do that elsewhere yeah yeah
no Jason with camera Jason I love it you
an American
okay so on the show Ted brings you the
biscuits right so okay so you have you
seen the actual cookie isn't actually
that good right they what season one
they were absolutely revolting okay no
like like a ceiling tile in a bathroom
it looks like like making all your
saliva disappear
crazy loon like oh
emotional support yeah like a crutch
emotional eating I don't know what
you're saying
oh mate yeah
they did get better okay do you think
it's because you were like I was like
God I don't know why they've got better
when you've complained about them
globally
I don't know what's happening man but
you know what if you add a lot of butter
and a lot of sugar you could be eating
an old shoe and it would taste nice
absolutely just pile on put in good
ingredients
so the show inspired an a new ice cream
flavor at Ginny's it's called biscuits
for the boss you haven't okay we didn't
know if you tried it so we have some we
want you I'm going to try it with you
I've never tried it either
you know you've made it when they make a
flavor is all I'm saying God this is
literally gonna do my hangover a treat
or you'll have an encore later that is
so much nicer than that
it's interesting because yeah it's got
the biscuit flavor I dug in to make sure
I had it all
right look big dirty chunks yeah it's
very short ready oh
it's very short ready I like it yeah I'm
just going to keep going go ahead
um I'm just warning you after a hangover
it might not end up anyway it might come
back you just host you posted one of my
favorite shows actually I love
Eurovision Eurovision Eurovision 2023.
oh my God how was it how is it being a
part of that estate just insane you grew
up on it yeah yeah totally great yeah
I'm from musical theater yeah because I
love Eurovision too with Will Ferrell
and Rachel yeah but they got that spot
on yeah I know but that's why I loved it
yeah yeah but that's figuration's
incredible guys
okay Monastery oh my God I love them and
then back in the day we had bucks Fizz I
mean which would never happen now yeah
like four four people group and two
girls and one part of the song the guys
whip the girl's skirts off and they've
got like Minis and I was like can you
imagine a woman going oh no that's cool
yeah let's do it oh my God I know but I
think that's what's so funny like the
and not funny but just entertaining is
like how
they're outrageous in the way that they
look like they're first of all in a
Vogue shoot all the time it's very
theatrical but like but their entire
like their aesthetic is cool and the
songs are rad like yeah I mean obviously
like Abba slaying down there's so many
winners
I absolutely I mean Celine Dion yeah God
what we would have given to hear her
sing back then with that I mean just
incredible yeah so it's been quite
overwhelming but I'd never worked with
an India
I am not the person I you know what I do
this
yeah you go like I look up and I'm just
like I hate I literally
please don't do that
it's not good it's not good for me
either I don't it's I don't do well I
have to stop myself going sorry 180
million people what yeah awful yeah I I
didn't get used to it I didn't at all
and then the crowd gets so loud and
you're like it almost sounds like
Charlie Brown's teacher
saying and we're on live television
anyway it was a hit
um okay so I don't know about you but I
am terrible at words like remembering
words
and I write them but I still forget them
yeah I literally the songs I write I
forget you do you forget your own words
oh my God I love this yeah I can
literally it's a talent I can be staring
at the words and still sing something
different I don't know what
yeah and I'm ADHD so I'm also my brain
is just always thinking about science
I'm a little bit like squirrel yeah oh
that's literally what I say I say is
squirrel yeah okay so we're so much
alike
um so should we play a game to find out
who's worse yes let's see how bad I am
let's do it yes
[Applause]
tomorrow night on Apple TV Plus
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you